[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález chile fue a las
urnas en unas elecciones presidenciales
y parlamentarias y el resultado dejó ver
un mensaje claro en torno a la división
y visión de país que tienen los
ciudadanos de chile dos candidatos
completamente opuestos en el espectro
político pasaron a la segunda vuelta
presidencial que tendrá lugar el 19 de
diciembre se trata de josé antonio kast
del partido republicano y de una
coalición que encarna los valores de la
extrema derecha chilena casta paso a la
segunda vuelta en la primera posición al
recibir el 27 91 por ciento de los votos
seguido por gabriel boric de la
coalición de izquierda en una coalición
que es conocida como apruebo dignidad
ellos obtuvieron el 25 83 por ciento de
los votos
kast y boris representan sentir es muy
diferentes de las de la ciudadanía una
mirada muy diferente de cómo debe ser el
futuro de chile tras el estallido social
y también la elaboración de una nueva
carta magna que está en proceso veamos
de quién se trata
gabriel boric y josé antonio kast van a
segunda vuelta en chile los dos
candidatos que lideran las encuestas
competirán por llegar al palacio de la
moneda boric un ex líder estudiantil
representa a la izquierda y es el más
joven de los siete candidatos que se
presentaron las elecciones el mismo
tiene 35 años la edad mínima para
postularse a la presidencia propone dar
un giro hacia un modelo de bienestar y
asegurar derechos sociales se trata de
que la esperanza legal el miedo en el
estallido social de 2019 jugó un papel
protagónico en apoyar el cambio de la
constitución representa a la coalición
apruebo dignidad que reúne al frente
amplio y al partido comunista alianza
que aprovechan sus detractores para
criticarlo lo atacan por su
inexperiencia y su falta de título
universitario también por su cambio de
postura en su respaldo al gobierno
venezolano que ahora rechaza el otro
extremo está el ultraderechista cast que
propone mantener el modelo neoliberal
promete imponer orden seguridad y
libertad tras dos años de protesta
social
guardan muchas opiniones esperar que la
gente en mi caso cast representa el
partido republicano está casado y tiene
nueve hijos es un activo miembro del
movimiento católico conservador randstad
es hijo de inmigrantes alemanes su padre
se alistó era el ejército durante el
régimen nazi alemán sus detractores lo
acusan por su admiración a la dictadura
de augusto pinochet y de líderes
controvertidos como yahir bolsonaro o
donald trump los dos candidatos opuestos
en su visión a tiza en la polarización
chile celebrará la segunda vuelta el
próximo 19 de diciembre
pues esta segunda vuelta por supuesto
genera muchas preguntas que lecturas se
puede hacer de esta votación que es
completamente opuesta que tanto afectará
la polarización en la ciudadanía de
dónde o a dónde irán a parar los votos
de los otros cinco candidatos que
participaron en esta primera vuelta de
las presidenciales qué futuro puede
tener la nueva constitución dependiendo
del candidato que llegue al palacio de
la moneda chile se está jugando su
futuro en estos comicios de eso no hay
ninguna duda además de escoger al futuro
sucesor de sebastián piñera los chilenos
también escogieron 155 miembros de la
cámara de diputados- 27 de los 50
senadores así tan así también como
consejeros regionales el reparto de las
fuerzas políticas en el legislativo
también evidencia el panorama político
de este país suramericano veamos algunas
imágenes en la cámara baja o la cámara
de diputados los partidos de los
candidatos más fuertes en esta elección
presidencial no alcanzaron mayoría por
lo que va a ser necesario hacer alianzas
si le podemos más tiene 53 escaños el
partido nuevo pacto social logró 37
mientras que apruebo dignidad 36 las
tres fuerzas más representativas de
acuerdo a las votaciones en el senado o
cámara alta chile podemos más logró dos
escaños nuevo pacto social ocho escaños
y apruebo dignidad cuatro escaños como
lo ve en un congreso en el que será
necesario como ya lo decía alianzas
coaliciones muy fuertes y también será
todo un reto para el mandatario que
llegue al palacio de la moneda
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
eduardo vergara director ejecutivo de la
fundación chile 21 también está con
nosotros rodrigo arellano él es vice
decano de la facultad de gobierno de la
universidad del desarrollo y también
está con nosotros aquí en el estudio de
france24 carolina cepeda profesor
asistente del departamento de relaciones
internacionales de la pontificia
universidad javeriana en la ciudad de
bogotá en colombia con quien vamos a
analizar el tema un poco más a nivel de
la región a nivel de lo que representan
estos votos presidenciales
para chile en el contexto continental
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden participar en el debate con todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas lo
pueden hacer a través de las redes
sociales nos pueden encontrar en
facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal y
el numeral o etiqueta es numeral debate
efe 24 esperamos todos sus comentarios y
sus preguntas a través de estos medios
comienza entonces con eduardo vergara
allí en chile- preguntándole por los dos
candidatos que pasan a esta segunda
vuelta qué lectura se puede hacer votos
de estos candidatos que representan
espectros completamente opuestos en el
panorama político de chile
lo primero es que la segunda vuelta de
cierta manera gráfica el fin de un ciclo
electoral que estaba marcado por dos
grandes coaliciones los partidos
compuestas por los partidos de la
transición y en esta segunda vuelta
ambas coaliciones ambos ambas
coaliciones de partidos políticos y sus
candidaturas quedan fuera es un elemento
no menor porque se repetía mucho a
medida que íbamos viendo los resultados
que por primera vez en décadas
ciertos partidos hegemónicos y
coaliciones hegemónicos no pasaban a la
segunda vuelta y esto se repite tanto
por la izquierda como por la derecha y
se marca por yo diría tres elementos
centrales el primero es la irrupción de
jose antonio kast que es una irrupción
que fue bastante rápida en comparación
con los movimientos y el comportamiento
de las otras candidaturas en los últimos
meses es marcada además por un factor
que resultó ser tremendamente importante
y gravitante que es la matriz del orden
y la seguridad que de cierta manera
en el discurso instalado por la
candidatura de josé antonio kast y de
cierta manera también lo hizo sebastián
sitges la candidatura que representaba a
los partidos convencionales de la
derecha y también a la continuidad del
gobierno y lo tercero es el factor
incertidumbre que se instala respecto a
lo que sucederá en la segunda vuelta si
bien la historia nos dice que quizá se
ha intentado no es cierto instalar y con
justa razón que quienes ganan la primera
vuelta siempre ganan en segunda vuelta
la diferencia entre ambas candidaturas
es mucho más acotada que en elecciones
anteriores entonces eso entrega una
apertura a que ambas candidaturas sean
tremendamente competitivas
rodrigo en la ciudad de santiago cuál es
su lectura
sobre estos dos espectros políticos
completamente diferentes que dice esto
de la ciudadanía chilena
en ninguna mirada bastante similar a la
deuda práctica que creo que la lección
de ayer de alguna otra forma marca el
cierre de un ciclo político que venía
desde después de la dictadura los dos
grandes ejes que habían gobernado
durante todo estos años no logran pasar
con su representante más tradicional a
esta segunda vuelta yo voy a hacer nada
puede hacer una pequeña aportación en la
presentación de la introducción de un
vídeo que es parte relevante también de
la cantidad dura de pasado tenía ocasión
bueno yo creo que muchos medios y
también parte importante del sector de
izquierdas lo utilizan te de
ultraderecha peligro que en eso están
cometiendo una especie de error y
equivocación porque la ultra derecha
tradicional en el mundo tiene valores
muy distintos lo que ha tenido que
probablemente si fuese ultraderechista
en en su esencia cas no es se lograba
basar la segunda vuelta y lo lo que
sigue una era una derecha más
conservadora
bastante lejana por cierto la de el
bolsón y donald trump
a veces a esa declaración por cierto
casting a sus orígenes en en un partido
muy tradicional de la centroderecha el
el fue tres veces diputado con amplias
mayorías siempre su zona y por algún
otro motivo que le causó un proyecto más
personal desde la derecha en el
pertenecer a un demócrata independiente
y en la elección pasada se desmarcó de
este bloque logró 18 por ciento la
votación elección pasada hoy ya está
cerca del 28 por ciento lo que lo deja
como hijo eduardo con una mirada
preferente para la segunda vuelta lo
deja mejor posicionado que boris para
hacer una vuelta por la razona histórica
es cierto que ambos candidatos si
quieren obtener el triunfo deben
convocar una amplia mayoría ninguna
ninguna ninguna vez el candidato que ya
ha ganado la primera vuelta el candidato
perdón que hagan la primera vuelta
siempre gana la elección pero nunca
habían tenido tan poca votación fíjate
siempre hemos estado en torno a los 35
40 por ciento en la 11 eso plantea un
desafío bien relevante para la segunda
vuelta cuál van a ser los ejes yo
coincido con él dado que el tema del eje
orden seguridad va a ser súper
importante en esta segunda vuelta y fue
lo que le dio gran gran crédito a casa
en esta primera está en curso en rápida
por justamente contrastar lo que era el
18 de octubre chilenos de orix
protagonista no solamente en el acuerdo
sino que también en las manifestaciones
versus el orden que probablemente en
esta en esta elección la gente alguna
forma hizo como un closer a ese modo a
ese minuto y quedar aquí delante a
partir construyendo un nuevo ciclo
político con un con más estabilidad
social rodrigo ya vamos a analizar
precisamente cómo hacer ese rompecabezas
de alianzas y refuerzos entre los dos
candidatos y cuáles pueden ser esos
mensajes claves para sacarle estudio
france24 carolina bienvenida al programa
los dos invitados allí en santiago hay
allí en chile m hablan del cierre de un
capítulo de una de una especie de cierre
de capítulo a nivel político los dos
partidos tradicionales o coaliciones
tradicionales que
y mal representados digámoslo así en
estas votaciones con los resultados que
tuvieron y se abren paso dos figuras
completamente diferentes que eran
conocidas en el espectro político pero
que no habían logrado trascender a una
instancia tan importante como una
elección presidencial que lectura se
puede hacer eso de la historia de la
democracia chilena y de la madurez
democrática que está adquiriendo el país
bueno pues yo creo que hay que tener en
cuenta varios elementos porque
efectivamente como dicen eduardo y
rodrigo claro hay un cierre o por lo
menos estamos como en el inicio de ese
de esa final de un capítulo pero es un
final que no empieza con estas
elecciones es un final que empieza en el
estallido social y que si uno quisiera
ser más generoso en el análisis y en el
tiempo uno diría que empieza a
desgastarse desde mucho tiempo atrás no
movilizaciones de estudiantes en 2011
movilizaciones estudiantes de secundaria
en 2006 y eso de alguna manera se puede
leer como un desgaste del modelo pero
también se puede leer como un proceso de
madurez democrática no entonces uno
puede pensar qué
es que digamos se ha caracterizado por
tener un sistema de partidos más de
coaliciones que propiamente de partidos
como podemos ver en otros países de la
región lo que uno va a encontrar es que
hay una suerte de desgaste claro porque
esas coaliciones también respondían a un
modelo de transición y post dictadura y
que el modelo se empieza a cuestionar
desde mucho tiempo atrás no ahí aparecen
movimientos sociales bien importantes
estudiantes movimientos indígenas los
ahorradores de los fondos privados de
pensiones y todos estos nos van a ver
van abriendo un camino más bien
mostrando unas demandas nuevas mostrando
un agotamiento de esa democracia hacia
la que se había transitado en chile una
limitación es una especie de no sólo
podría decir como incoherencia entre lo
que ocurre en todo lo que se dice en
términos democráticos y lo que son las
condiciones materiales de las personas y
lo que vamos a ver es que esa esos esos
ejercicios de movilización y esas
demandas inconclusos lo que están pues
de alguna manera diciendo es este modelo
de democracia ha sido insuficiente
necesitamos algo más y tenemos en este
momento dos polos opuestos no pero que
paradójicamente coinciden en qué de lo
que existe ha sido un suficiente y se
necesita ir hacia otra cosa hay que
abrir un debate y hay que abrir una
discusión hacia algo diferente que es
justamente lo que en el proceso que
chile arranca desde septiembre con la
con la asamblea constitucional
y a lo largo de estas semanas en
france24 hemos conversado con muchos
ciudadanos chilenos y muchos dicen que
tal vez aquí lo que se evidenció es el
chile verdadero que la imagen que
teníamos de ese país es tan organizado y
bien proyectado con una economía estable
y políticamente muy estable no era tan
maravilloso como como se pensaba y que
internamente había muchas deudas
pendientes a nivel social y eso lo que
ha comenzado a evidenciarse después del
estallido social y que bueno ya estamos
en esta instancia es uno de los temas
importantes de las candidaturas
presidenciales en paso a preguntarle a
eduardo y tal vez es la pregunta más
importante de este debate y es cómo se
pueden empezar a repartir esas fuerzas a
quienes pueden ir esos votos de los
otros cinco candidatos que ya se
quedaron atrás en esta contienda
electoral a quienes pueden apoyar como
es el rompecabezas que usted arma de
cara a la segunda vuelta a eduardo
y rompecabezas no tienen muchas piezas
en el sentido que por eso
analizamos y analizamos los resultados
nos damos cuenta que claramente hay dos
bloques lo que podríamos llamar la
amplia izquierda no es cierto y la
amplia derecha que está principalmente
compuesta por los partidos
convencionales más en
la candidatura de josé antonio kast pero
pero si tú sumas eso ambos bloques te
das cuenta que es prácticamente un
empate entonces hay dos hay dos factores
o dos mundos los cuales son los que
realmente entran en disputa uno es el
voto de parís y un candidato que desde
eeuu sin pisar chile
logró una votación muy importante el
tercer lugar
y que lo que hemos visto al menos cuenta
cuando un electorado que está compuesto
principalmente de hombres y personas que
se autodefinen como a políticos
fue bastante histórico también tener una
elección con tu presidente un candidato
al reciente nunca pisó chiles y no quiso
todo desde eeuu y con no es cierto una
secuencia de razones que primero
3 de kobe después que tenía comida
etcétera pero independiente de eso ahí
hay un universo y el segundo universo es
la quienes no votaron en la
participación electoral ronda en torno
al 47% hay un universo de votantes que
todavía pueden ser llamados a votar y
pueden generar ciertos incentivos para
que acudan y ahí es donde va a estar el
el elemento que puede definir esta
elección ahora rodrigo tocada dos puntos
muy importante yo los quiero tocar
rápidamente primero es el momentum cast
logra un momentum utah a un discurso que
genera una sensación de triunfo y ahí
está la principal de responsabilidad de
gabriel boric de ver cómo se revierte
eso y no tengo la menor duda que en los
próximos días veremos una cierta especie
de acoplamiento en las velocidades pero
no cabe la menor duda que josé antonio
partido con mayor velocidad y los
segundos que es lo que yo también
menciona al principio y tiene que ver
con esta matriz de orden y seguridad lo
que hemos visto en toda américa latina
colombia méxico centroamérica brasil
particularmente es que la derecha
siempre cuenta con mayor eficiencia en
hacerse cargo de los temas de seguridad
de entregar respuesta no son
necesariamente respuestas efectivas la
verdad es que si uno mira las cifras de
inseguridad en chile
en la gestión del presidente piñera ha
sido un fracaso en los homicidios fueron
en un 20 por ciento como claros una
cifra quienes nunca nos esperábamos los
delitos más violentos también etcétera
hay una serie de datos que nos ayudan a
entender esto pero cuando llega el
momento de ofrecer
y hacerla rendir electoralmente la
derecha siempre tiene un camino
recorrido y es en este momento no fue la
sección si rodrigo su opinión
como en la lección talleres yo creo
fue como repite revitalizadora para la
centroderecha ya lo dijo bien eduardo
venía a la centroderecha muy golpeada lo
que había sido la elección de
constituyente en mayo del proceso
constitucional chileno en donde no
alcanzó el tercio necesario para poder
incluir las decisiones de esta
convención y el día de ayer obtiene casi
70 parlamentarios de la cámara diputado
fenomenal y la mitad del senado se
recuperó un estatus que al parecer lo
había perdido entonces eso le distraiga
yo yo tengo la impresión de una fuerza
distinta para enfrentar la segunda
vuelta lo mismo que los 2 antonio kast
que anoche fue bastante más inteligente
desde el punto de vista que lo que lo
hizo vori vori en su discurso de
reconocimiento en segundo lugar le habló
básicamente a sus votantes
para reafirmar el voto
de centroizquierda duro que obtuvo y lo
que hizo cas en su discurso fue
agradecer por supuesto a sus votos pero
amplió inmediatamente el espectro a otro
hizo guiños importante a la candidatura
de sitges a la candidatura de nombró a
lavín abrió nada deporte que ha decido
contendores que existen en la primaria
la centroderecha de hecho en un minuto
él se sacó la insignia de su partido
político y dijo que renunciaba a su
partido a dirigirlo en el presidente el
partido republicano para de alguna forma
de enfrentar este segundo tiempo este
segundo lapso más libre de su partido y
ha abierto amplios cambios y por lo
tanto creo que la primera señal fue muy
clara
entendió rápidamente que según abortar
tiene mayoría yo tiendo a mirar con una
lógica diferente piquete si nosotros
sumamos la votación de parís y que tiene
ocasión eduardo de una votación distinta
extraña que pueden cantar ya lo vamos a
analizar también
entendimiento que está pero pero esa
votación en en la elección anterior
te envió a irse será en su gran mayoría
él también tuvo una votación relevante
la vez pasada no tanto como ahora y todo
estudió los cursos información que
nosotros vimos el día hoy es que la
votación parís y el año 2017 se fue en
su gran mayoría hacia
sebastián piñera que de hecho logró por
eso lo que obtener la segunda el triunfo
en segunda vuelta por tanto uno tiende a
pensar y si las fuerzas no izquierdas
suman 53 por ciento y si no dicen
mayores alteraciones en lo que vamos
viendo la segunda campaña insisto que
quedó en el primer lugar de la cuerpos y
yo os antonio kast para lograr de manera
inesperada hace algunos meses una vez
hecho el triunfo el próximo 19 diciembre
en carolina quien el estudio de france
analizamos el panorama de esta primera
de esta primera ronda electoral dos
candidatos que son la misma las mismas
dos caras de la moneda que vemos en
américa latina izquierda derecha que es
como lo habitual que tenemos en la
región vemos este candidato que nunca
pisó chile hizo una campaña digital
virtual y lograr la tercera posición con
el 12 80% de los votos y solamente una
mujer eso dice mucho de la política
chilena que solamente haya tenido una
mujer en esta participación que han
tenido presidenta pero no solamente del
índice de la política chilena sino de la
política latinoamericana yo creo que es
el mismo escenario en diversos espacios
pero claro si empezamos a ver por
ejemplo lo que ocurre en términos de
partidos políticos la participación que
tienen las mujeres en los partidos en
los movimientos de base vemos que la
participación es mayor sin embargo claro
aquí pues entre los candidatos y los
candidatos que pasen la segunda vuelta
además son dos hombres
pues eso sí creo que ilustra bastante
bien lo que es la política
latinoamericana y pues para ser
simplemente
escandaloso es la política global donde
las mujeres pues ciertamente no tenemos
el mismo espacio que se tiene en los
puntos en los digamos en las posiciones
de poder dentro de los partidos
políticos o dentro de las coaliciones yo
quería agregar algo frente al análisis
que estaban haciendo eduardo y rodrigo
porque me parece muy importante ver esta
candidatura de parís y que que si en
algunos medios le dicen aún lo que es
ambiguo pero pero ciertamente es un
votante con un perfil muchísimo más de
derecha y pues si uno suma pues uno dios
diría que tal vez la tendencia se va a
mantener y es que quien ganó la primera
vuelta seguramente ganará la segunda
vuelta pero ahí creo que es clave
también pensar en este punto que
mencionaba eduardo sobre la extensión
pero es una extensión muy difícil de
movilizar no no se movilice o lo
suficientemente para el plebiscito
tampoco se movió a nuestros espacios que
probablemente invitaban a la gente a
salir entonces aquí surgen preguntas de
quiénes son las mismas que más ex tienen
de ir a votar cómo moverlos hacia qué
lado se inclinarían y a quién
terminarían favoreciendo en ese pues en
ese futuro escenario yo creo que esa
discusión pues supongo que la vamos a
analizar es bastante interesante ahora
sí tengo la pregunta sobre el
abstencionismo precisamente para hacerse
la carolina más adelante le pregunto
ahora hago la ronda a la inversa
comienzo con rodrigo en la ciudad de
santiago preguntándole por los mensajes
como estos dos candidatos pueden
aproximarse a más votantes ganarse votos
de estos indecisos ya lo veíamos una
alta abstención para el escenario
habitual de las elecciones
presidenciales chilenas cuáles van a ser
esos mensajes es como aproximarse ambos
candidatos de hecho todos los candidatos
recibieron muchas críticas a lo largo de
las campañas por tener unos programas y
no muy bien estructurados ser ambiguos
con algunos mensajes no conocer
información sobre algunos temas fueron
criticados porque tenían un plan de
trabajo un plan de gobierno pero en
algunos puntos hasta los mismos
candidatos discrepaban sobre el mismo
plan que ellos están proponiendo que es
un escenario muy
extraño para entender cuáles van a ser
entonces esos mensajes claves
yo creo que eso tiene una razón fíjate
ambos candidatos tengo la impresión no
estaban preparados de alguna otra forma
para el resultado de este domingo tal no
yo tengo la visión que debo dicho nunca
pensó que iba a estar disputando la
presidencia del país como con santonio
casi nunca pensó tampoco que iba a estar
ganando la primera vuelta de la forma
que lo hizo ayer por lo tanto estos
errores programáticos reflejan un poco
eso la sorpresa la poca preparación que
de alguna forma tuvieron yo tengo la
impresión que esta segunda vuelta no
solamente están marcados por los por los
mensajes centrales por las emociones
directos de persona acá tengo una
segunda vuelta a memoria emocional donde
lo programático bajar un poquito de lado
y vengo la impresión pero pero una de
las cosas que van a tener que hacer
ambos candidatos es moderarse hacia el
centro en algunas de sus posturas cuál
va a ser esa buena van a ser esos ejes
fundamentales sin perder la esencia cada
uno si cada uno está puesto ahí porque
tiene una esencia que lo identifica pero
ellos para tener que de alguna forma
entregar o ceder en algunas posturas de
moderación por ejemplo casa antonio
casas va a tener que yo tengo la empezar
a hacer un guiño con respecto al tema
del cambio climático que fue
multiplicada por parte de su contendor o
el agotamiento de los de
ministerio a la mujer que a él se le
criticó que lo eliminaba y el de se
quede que funciona libre a tener que
ceder a ese tipo de cosas bonito va a
ser más complicado porque el mejor
eduardo no sé si coincide conmigo en eso
porque bonnici carga y a diferencia de
cash con una máquina muy pesada en la
mochila del partido comunista de hecho
hoy tuvieron varios conflictos con
respecto a esto boris al criticó muy
duramente al ex contendor que tuvo el
partido con esta venir a ver y el
partido cuenta le respondió duramente
hoy y esa mochila va a ser difícil de
movilizando hacia hacia posiciones más
moderadas tratar de captar un voto más
concertación tradicional que se el eje
que tuvo dominantes quiere después de la
dictadura
pero siento va a tener que hacer eso
guiños hacia el orden guiño hacia la
democracia clara críticas hacia las
dictaduras latinoamericanas que de
alguna forma lo conflictúan con sus
socios del partido comunista pero la
clave va a ser moderación en algunos
aspectos y mantener la esencia cada uno
de esta primera vuelta clara demás boris
ha recogido mucho en su campaña de este
sentimiento social precisamente que
viene del estallido social de hace dos
años y eso ha generado mucha expectativa
en particular de la sociedad chilena y
eso también genera mucha presión en esa
candidatura porque mucha expectativa de
cambio que tanto margen va a tener para
poder actuar y para poder generar tantos
cambios cuál es su opinión entonces
sobre sobre este tema eduardo sobre
cuáles van a ser esos temas claves
centrales para convencer al electorado
convencer a los a los indecisos y ganar
adeptos de las otras formaciones
políticas
sabes creo que el campo de las próximas
menos días de tres semanas que están
quedando hasta hasta las elecciones va a
ser una carrera bastante rápida y
bastante corta concuerdo en que el tema
programático no va a tener el
protagonismo que tomó en la primera
vuelta lo que va a ser clave son los
mensajes centrales las señales que se
envían creo que gabriel tiene una
ventaja muy grande en que a diferencia
de josé antonio kast tiene una mayor
capacidad para movilizar a quienes no
fueron las botas de sin duda que es un
elector más duro pero la participación
del plebiscito fue mayor que las
elecciones del día domingo hay un margen
todavía que mover y creo que tal como
algunos les gusta instalar y recalcar y
extrapolar muchas veces el factor
partido comunista lo que está en juego
frente a la llegada de casas si bien no
es un no es la extrema derecha como la
conocemos en brasil o en otros países es
una persona que reniega a la dictadura
que no quiere hablar de dictaduras se
niega a hablar la dictadura que ha hecho
una serie de gestos a presos y a
personas que
violaron los derechos humanos durante
este periodo entonces creo que este es
un factor no menor porque obviamente lo
que está en juego es quien va a gobernar
el país creo que la historia va a jugar
un rol relevante en la segunda vuelta si
bien los programas fueron gravitantes en
esta primera instancia no creo que ahora
va a pesar mucho la historia y va a
pensar el país que queremos y la
pregunta es si queremos a la cabeza del
país una persona que niega que en la
dictadura hubo una serie de violaciones
a los derechos humanos y cuando quiso
comparar esto con nicaragua dijo que en
chileno a los adherentes políticos no se
les desaparecía ni detenida y que habían
elecciones democráticas entonces esa ese
es un factor no menor que creo que sin
duda va a ser central en lo que se viene
la próxima semana y con ello creo que
gabriel tiene todas las posibilidades de
unir a un electorado que quiere cambios
y demostrar que las caricaturas que se
quieren instalar sobre su campaña
solamente estrategias políticas que no
tienen mucho sustento
a ver carolina vemos a estos dos
personajes son
b1 como como una una balanza entre el
cambio versus tranquilidad tal vez es
como lo que se están enfrentando los
chilenos también como experiencia
política juventud nueva experiencia
nueva generación son
como lo
lógico y creo que no necesariamente esta
experiencia a ver versus cambio
incertidumbre porque yo creo que estamos
ante dos candidatos que tiene una
trayectoria cada uno desde su lugar
desde donde se han movido desde donde se
han construido políticamente y eso pues
creo que en ambos casos es innegable si
a un hombre le puede gustar más uno que
el otro pero creo que ambos tienen una
trayectoria tienen una experiencia
electoral previa tienen una experiencia
política importante pero lo que yo sí
creo es que en este en esta fase que
como bien dicen eduardo y rodrigo van a
jugar las emociones que es lo que ha
jugado también en buena parte de
elecciones en américa latina en los
últimos cinco años y hemos votado más
con el hígado y el corazón que con la
cabeza muchas veces en colombia en
brasil en muchos lugares
y eso pasa factura también pero lo que
yo sí creo es que aquí también que los
candidatos se enfrentan a ser fieles a
su a su propio proyecto político ya su
propio origen político no lo digo en un
sentido y es que si bien en la derecha
con jose antonio kast se la está jugando
ahora por volver sobre el discurso del
orden de la seguridad de los inmigrantes
y toda la cosa que eso da muchos votos
desde un sector del electorado por
supuesto tenemos a gabriel boric que
también tiene que descender un poco ese
inconformismo que se venía gestando en
chile que se
que se materializó en el estallido
social en 2019 y también hablarle a ese
electorado yo no creo que sea erróneo
hablarle y focalizarse en ese electorado
precisamente porque ese es su programa
no puede las banderas de la
derecha de repente simplemente para
ganar votos porque ahora tal vez
terminaría y jugándole un poco un poco
en contra a qué se enfrenta el
electorado chileno ahorita yo creo que
se enfrenta
a hacer realidades de cambio que se
soñaron y que se pensaron en 2019 versus
a ponerle una serie de obstáculos y una
serie de trabas al proceso que se está
gestando en la asamblea en la asamblea
constituyente y otro que esa es una de
las cosas que que tienen sobre la mesa
los chilenos ahora y que definitivamente
pues va a marcar el futuro eso me lleva
a mi última pregunta ya me quedan tres
minutos de programa le pidió a rodrigo
por favor que sea muy puntual para dar
paso a las conclusiones y es el futuro
de la carta magna de la nueva
constitución y qué futuro le puede
esperar dependiendo del presidente que
llegue al palacio de la moneda
son
yo creo que el proceso va a ser muy
distinto si vas a va a ser
en distintos si llega bonito se llega a
castilla tecnológica diferente sea
funciona por un carril distinto yo más
bien creo que la presidencia o las
instituciones van a depender de este
otro proceso
sin duda yo creo y lo que ha pasado en
la ciudadanía es que
el inconformismo previo octubre se
canalizó yo tengo la impresión con este
proceso constituyente por lo tanto sí
porque sigue apelando a los turismo o al
18 de octubre oa los sentimientos que
tenían los chilenos pero ese proceso es
probable que ese camino lo llevó a la
derrota porque la ciudadanía desde mí de
mirar en el camino ese sentimiento de
malestar de disgusto justamente en el
proceso constituyente es lo que nos está
funcionando
la impresión mía es que va a dar lo
mismo en quien gane la presidencia
porque este proceso ocurra por un querer
distinto es más la presidencia está
sujeta a proceso de rodrigo el play
queda 2 minuto del programa por favor
rápidamente su conclusión rápido por
favor
con
los mensajes
en esta segunda vuelta en la semana que
va a ganar los mensajes de orden de
seguridad tengo una impresión que logre
convocar más personas quien logra
activar esa votación de parís y
que
esta va a tener un triunfo el próximo 19
de isla mento lamento tenerlo que cortar
pero quiero que todos puedan hacer las
conclusiones eduardo su conclusión que
puede seguir para el país para esta
segunda vuelta presidencial y el futuro
de la constitución
a ver primero cuatro semanas
tremendamente fascinante creo que vamos
a tener una diversidad de escenario si
hay algo que aprendimos la primera
vuelta es que la encuesta se movieron
muy rápido y los escenarios cambiaron
candidatos que estaban arriba bajaron lo
bien paso en candidaturas al senado y a
los parlamentarios es el primer elemento
lo segundo es que lo que está en juego
es demasiado importante tocaste el tema
del plebiscito de salida lo que va a ser
la convención y el guardián que se va a
ser un factor que va a ayudar a
determinar la elección de la ciudadana y
ciudadano
rápidamente aquí en el estudio la dejo
para el cierre carolina 15 segundos la
conclusión no concuerdo plenamente en
que van a hacer cuatro semanas de
infarto debate muy álgido pero también
de candidatos que van a tener que
repensar y fortalecer un poco sus
mensajes pero por esa misma vía también
van a tener que fortalecer sus programas
porque van a tener que mostrarse
muchísimo más sólidos y una ciudadanía
que yo creo que tiene que estar
tremendamente activa y muy muy metida y
entender que también por la vía
electoral se participa bueno pues a
carolina rodrigo a eduardo y gracias por
habernos acompañado este cierre fue más
rápido que nunca nos había tocado así
lamento verlos interrumpido pero pues se
me fue el tiempo más rápido lo que
esperaba a ustedes muchas gracias por la
sintonía pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]